Tucker Carlson is back he put up a video
on Twitter saying that he'll be
launching a new show on Twitter and the
News comes after it was reported that
Tucker Carlson met with Elon Musk now
the interpretation for most people was
that they came to some kind of Accord
but Elon Musk came out and said there's
no deal Tucker is just gonna do a show
on Twitter but we will see it feels like
what they're really saying is they have
not signed anything and this could be
for legal reasons due to Tucker's
current contract with Fox News but it
does seem like Tucker and Elon have a
plan of sorts so this is big interesting
stuff but there's more news in the
Tucker front apparently it's being
reported he was fired as part of the
Dominion settlement as if to imply that
Dominion was like okay we'll set up you
gotta fire Tucker Carlson which is very
very strange to say the least